este hombre y su hijo son migrantes
afganos y regresan al campo de moore y
en busca de material que pueda servirles
en el nuevo campo de karate ellos son
parte de los 12.700 demandantes de asilo
que se quedaron en la calle tras el
incendio del 8 de septiembre
y mi casa estaba allí esa noche todo se
quemó había fuego por todos lados vine a
buscar estos plásticos para construir un
techo en el nuevo campo
aquí estaba el corazón del campo de
memoria en esta calle por ejemplo
funcionaba un mercado a cielo abierto en
estos contenedores vivían algunos de los
migrantes y en este edificio funcionaba
la oficina de asilo de la unión europea
todas estas instalaciones están
completamente destruidas y nadie sabe
todavía qué va a pasar con ellas
por estos días funcionarios municipales
intentan limpiar el lugar
como habitantes de la pequeña localidad
de moria este incendio criminal marca
para ellos el final de cinco años de
crisis vivida en primera línea
de 'feeling' seeds mix siempre una
mezcla de tristeza miseria al comienzo
había niños sin zapatos que caminaban
por las calles que lloraban y nosotros
los ayudamos pero siempre junto a las
buenas personas hay otras que causan
problemas with people
breaking bad people to make el show
es malo es triste queremos lo mejor para
ellos pero también para nosotros los
locales hasta 20.000 demandantes de
asilo estuvieron bloqueados en los
momentos más duros de la crisis
migratoria en lesbos una isla que tiene
85 mil habitantes
migrantes y locales coinciden al menos
en no querer que un nuevo moría renazca
de las cenizas